two hey
it's off the rails come on
i saw some people worried we wouldn't be
back off the rails but once you're off
the rails you're
always off the idle you're not getting
[Music]
you know we just had a we had a busy few
weeks with fighting and
interviewing and roasting but we're off
the rails we're not going anywhere we
have a fantastic show today that i'm
very
uh excited to bring you guys sponsored
by kraken
public and upstart you know we did the
roast on
for my birthday last week and um
first of all everyone did fantastic yes
last week's after dark fantastic roast
for my birthday thank you everybody
thank you thank you round of applause
i'm 36 which is you know pretty [ __ ]
old
yes yes yes don't feel a day over 50.
[Applause]
is it that bad i mean people think i
look 50 so i'm just
playing up to that be honest with me do
you guys think that i look
36 just be honest don't don't just
no i would say you look exactly the age
that you are
okay yeah i think i think you look
younger than what you are i think your
hair might throw it out you don't want
it maybe you're the only one who thinks
that i know i swear
okay av is great
god bless don't ask ian he'll be like i
think i thought you were 80.
i think you look your age i think you're
age appropriate it's not appropriate
there's a lot of there's contradicting
factors going on is the thing you got
the hairline of an 18 year old but the
hair
color of like a 50 year old right i
think that averages out to about 36. the
gray hair throws people off
for sure in the hands of a 10 year old
come on
i'm sorry i say that i'm sorry it was
too freaky why would you say that i'm
just saying you look youthful
in general that's not what you said you
said why would you say that this roast
was last week
i'm so sorry i was it was too perfect
god you're such an [ __ ] that was just
bro you you can't be saying [ __ ] like
that you really crossed the line you
really crossed the line
i'm deducting five percent from your
salary
[ __ ]
five percent means everything you know
well a lot of people were saying uh
there was lots of memes about the roast
that i'm just gonna be honest with i
thought i handled it well
people were saying oh ethan's michael
scott from the office
i was not i handled it well i i actually
fully agree with you i i thought you
were gracious
uh i didn't i didn't think that you
seemed bitter about it at all
thank you i was like geez bro i was like
i did this roast for myself trying to be
gracious and
having fun and people are still saying
i'm michael scott
i got to ask one question though
regarding the roast
why did you only hug a b um because he
just seemed
he seemed very fragile like he really
needed it
and by the way after that hand statement
maybe don't be
[ __ ] asking me to go light on your
frat glass
yeah no i sounded uh very shaky i guess
so everyone's like oh ethan caresome i
mean we care so much about ethan that's
why but
so it was a hug well listen i'll be on i
think i if i remember
i can't remember that clearly i think
one of the jokes ian said is that i have
the memory of a goldfish or something
that was that was me well that was dan
see there we go
there you go but um
i think av is the only one that actually
made an attempt to say something
genuinely nice after the roast
mm-hmm all you guys were like you suck
you're a douche
that's not true at all he's the only one
who talked about the hands
don't try and put that on yeah he took
the [ __ ] low blow and you give him a
hug
yeah you guys all want hugs come line up
i'll give you all right i'm a hug
actually no let's get the hug
hugs going yeah i don't know we're good
we're good on hugs i'll take one after
the show
all right zach i think zach needs a hug
exactly to hug most days yeah
i always yeah that is more deserving of
hugs than maybe zach is
excuse me oh because the hand yeah okay
sure well anyway here's the memes he
says uh
uh ethan after the royals i spent the
afternoon in the park trying to feed the
pigeons
i guess they all flew west for the
winter
not true i went home and i was fine
this one's fine i guess
[Music]
what did you make that face i i don't
remember making that face
me neither i do not want to [ __ ] my
sister
shout out to gladiator though that was a
great movie oh right
yeah he wanted to [ __ ] his sister thank
you boom roasted this is a good um
analogy it is yeah
ethan today you know it's like come on
i am not michael scott how dare you i
love this image though yeah this one's
great when you're getting roasted by the
group chat and just reply lol like it's
no big deal
[Laughter]
that is a great photo definitely hand it
to whoever snipped that one
[Music]
when it's a row session and you about to
light the homie up
ian looking demonic bro
terrifying wasn't hugging ian after that
[ __ ] i'll tell you that
love me daddy you can tell it hurt abe
to have to roast ethan ethan while a.b
was roasting his tiny hands
[Music]
you know you know i'm insecure about
that maybe
and that's something trisha brought up
and for you to actually bring that up
now
twice i just blow the belt i didn't know
you're insecure about it
you denied it when trisha brought it up
you're like i have normal hands and then
[ __ ] you baby
i am i of course i'm insecure about
having little baby hands what the [ __ ]
you think
what the [ __ ] you think they're not that
small
yeah they're not that small shut up
uh the roast versus the n i think that's
just you know
that's just any episode yeah exactly i
don't know that's not an attack
um ian the satanic employee why are
there so many
shots yeah looking like a what's going
on here ian
i don't know it's very unsettling
they just got they just found one frame
you know i wonder
please stand up no because the other one
that had him looking like that had the
the uh scrolls behind oh it's a
different moment a different moment oh
my god ian
damn ethan when he sees his birthday
cake was that i think that was from the
birthday kid
really nice yes didn't eat a lot of it
though so come on that looks like your
favorite part of the show
every cartoon villain bro i think i
roasted myself i looked so
fat i looked so [ __ ] fat let me pull
up this tick tock
god
yeah he should just be saying cake ethan
i left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt that i wanted
i know the pan girl and then i had a
hard time the rest of the week today is
my birthday
look how fat i look i look like one of
these dudes like my face is normal but
my face is
my body is so [ __ ] have gathered do
you know what i'm saying
the [ __ ] out of me it's a it's an angle
issue
look it's a combination of the angle and
that chair
just kind of forces you to sit in a very
awkward position yeah let me just mute
it nobody i don't care
the chair um the chair is one of the
most uncomfortable chairs i've ever sat
in
just straight up yeah there's no lumbar
it's just a straight rigid
it's so bad you you kind of you kind of
look like heat miser
when he tried to ruin christmas do you
know what i'm talking about
no no you don't know the rest but i've
got a body like uh i mean
pear-shaped i mean it really is a
pear-shaped body
it's like a roasted pear
anyway here's more small hand jokes it's
good to know our king has a back
has a backup business in case h3 fails
ethan's little hands
crooks crannies holes not a single place
these tiny hands can't go
that was just that was a line straight
from uh ian's roast was it not
he was proposing that as a business
venture free no that was yeah
oh that was a b i'm sorry right maybe i
said in the world really holding in on
that yeah
yeah ethan's little hands
and this is me in my college room
waiting for you to arrive
so anyway but on a serious note thank
you guys were all super funny that was a
great event that you guys put on
and uh it was fantastic so great work
everyone
i just wanted to review the um the roast
memes frankly
and uh five percent meme still going
strong
there's there's a cosmic thing going on
in the universe now that we've been
thinking about five percent
it's showing up everywhere we see joe
rogan talking about joe rogan is very
passionate about the five percent
five percent difference is astronomical
it's everything
five percent means everything yeah uh
here's me apparently talking about five
percent that people were freaking out
about there's no such thing as a
coincidence
this was an old pod that reached the
deal you know
they'll get there they'll they'll figure
it out this disney's like look dude
we just upped our disney tickets to 200
dollars for
per for just a one day pass we've
we've we're stretching everything we're
making as much
we don't know where to get more revenue
so
we're gonna need more than five percent
you believe how much it costs to go to
disneyland
no it's crazy man
or they'll reach the deal that's five
percent you know
and a discussion about the price of
disney tickets it's like crazy it's dude
prophetic
it's it's crazy the five percent is sewn
into the fabric of the universe and
exists at five percent
yeah i know we're gonna need more than
five percent
oh okay so and then i know we talked
about brittany
last week but there's been some
fantastic free britney updates
specifically you know that we love wendy
williams and wendy williams went off
and we're all free brittany here but you
know wendy williams takes everything way
too far
and she said something that even freaked
herself out wendy williams went full
isis
and it's [ __ ] amazing watch this [ __ ]
bro this is
the clip of the it's so
funny you guys
she literally went full isis and freaked
her and the whole audience turned on her
real quick
watch this how dare you mr spears you
had me fooled
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them
what happened look at her face
you're a little kid
and she's the audience immediately turns
on her and she's
she like it's like who said that watch
this
oh why is it muted
the [ __ ] happened why is it muted did
you is it muted on reddit i didn't do
[ __ ] dude i just played the [ __ ]
video
why was it muted
all right mrs spears death to all of
them
even the audience seemed to think wendy
williams went too
far
i love the background they're like jesus
yeah you heard somebody like jesus
it's the best thing ever one more time
how dare you mr spears you had me fooled
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them what happened
even the audience she would full isis
she's ready to behead jamie spears
the emphasis on death is what made it so
exciting death to
all of them when have you ever uttered
death to all of them to all of them when
has anybody ever out of those words
that's not like a jihadist or something
death to all of them i could think one
example but it'll get us demonetized
yeah yeah oh right yeah he said death
toll
people that look like me who practice
the same religion
yeah death to all of them dude that's
the best that's so
fun it's so funny wendy williams is the
funniest person on tv
hands down as you had me fooled
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them
who says that what is this
death to all of them
[Applause]
[ __ ] oh someone says they edited out of
the youtube upload
that's fantastic yeah i wonder why oh
well it's going to live here forever
wendy
zach's got his finger on the button
forever death to all of them
oh god
yeah britney's coming out though i'm
team brittany all the way bro i i can't
the more i learn about this the more
just i'm just like
um girl we need britney's life back
now she filed to end the the um
conservatorship
it's happening we're free and brittany
we are free
and we are and not and that doesn't stop
there we are
killing everybody involved we are not we
disavow
any threat of violence on this show oh
this is a mess i was just following
wendy's to the youtube raiders we
death do not do all of them we do not
want anyone dead to all of them
death i'm just following wendy's lead
i'm just following orders
death death
oh britney's out britney's mask off man
she posted
i'm here in maui it's pretty crazy now
the paps know where i am and it's really
not fun you know i gotta say
this poor woman she's still being
hounded by the paparazzi
after everything she's been through
she's kind of stepped out of the
limelight now
in the middle years of her life
but this girl cannot stay out of the
of the of the lens of the public with
this whole
you know conservatorship now and this
[ __ ] paparazzi are back at it
hey man dude death's all of them
[Laughter]
oh peace and love only i'm just
following the paparazzi we love the
paparazzi i'm just following orders
she says it's pretty hard to go anywhere
because these silly faces keep popping
up and taking my picture not only do
they take my picture they distort my
body and mess with the image and it's
embarrassing
i know my body's not perfect but i
definitely do not look like how they
betray me
it's rude it's mean so pap kindly [ __ ]
you and
[ __ ] you and death to all of them
death to all of them
death to all of them death to all of
them man
anyway she got a video here
dude i i believe the paparazzi are like
distorting or
[ __ ] to make it more clicky
if you're a pat don't talk to me while
i'm texting
it's rude don't talk to me while i'm
texting
work it girl work it we are out on the
beach in maui living our best life
this is my body stop messing with my
picks and editing them to the point
where it's embarrassing
to all of them
i love this video man where who edited
this is [ __ ] awesome dude
i wonder if she edited this herself it's
fantastic content britney spears
instagram is uh on unbeaten on
that what's the word it's it's uh it's
undefeated thank you yeah
she said the title of this post is [ __ ]
you
bop mute you see that the title is [ __ ]
you
mask off britney it's britney [ __ ]
death to all of them
oh i think that is the title of the lily
allen song
oh it is oh that's racing to all of them
you know what i think about those
paparazzis death to all of them death
it's thing the best can't
[Music]
um one other thing you know i want to
talk about at the top
uh shout out to ringo star friend of the
show peace and love peace and love
this is a serious message from ringo
starr's lingle team
we are dropping our lawsuit against the
ringo
penis ring peace and love peace and love
ringo starr drops legal battle against
ringo penis rings
that's a bit of a stretch ringo let's be
honest
i'm gonna come star filed a lawsuit in
2019 objecting to the name of the penis
ring
he claimed the brand was identical in
appearance sound connotation and
pronunciation to his own name
i mean it's the it's the
ringo penis i mean it's a first name bro
you can
i mean come on down i'm dick tiff dick
tip
i mean ringo isn't his actual name right
yeah it's richard well so i mean
whatever it is
you can't just own ringo right are there
any other ringos
i mean if you're if you're he kind of
does own it well copyright works like if
it's someone
who's doing a musical act then we can
discuss copyright
someone's making a penis ring that's a
whole different well maybe he's planning
on
branching out to some new uh industries
if ringo
is planning on launching his own penis
ring called the ringo which is an
interesting idea yeah i mean it's not
maybe you should partner with them then
you may have an ip
dispute why doesn't he i mean he should
be the face of the ringo
this penis ring is interesting it looks
like a lifesaver i mean
yeah if you look up ringo pro products
on google you'll see like herbal oils
anti-fungal creams dog toys ring
cleaners
wow juice really yeah i'm gonna come
not his products not his products that's
what i'm saying huh so anyway peace and
love to the ringo penis ring we are
dropping all legal charges after the
date of june 30th peace and love peace
and love
peace and love peace and love shout out
okay was one other thing i wanted to
discuss here before we get into it
today we're going to be talking about
trisha paytas obviously i don't know if
you've seen she apologized to me i'm
going to be responding to that
and um austin mcbroom
you know we've we've talked about the
ace family bro this guy is the
sketchiest dude on the internet bro
and he's just schemed a bunch of
millions of dollars from a bunch of
other people
but the final thing is you know the fire
haircuts we've talked about fire
haircuts before on the show
and i've expressed interest in wanting
to do it myself
and uh let me refresh your memory a
little bit
we have a barber here on standby who's
going to be doing a fire haircut for me
today
yeah let's go that's what i'm talking
about now i've been wanting to do try
the fire haircut
oh these guys have badass hair so they
can't be wrong about it
fire that little bit of music that was
like the
the gannon funeral music that was played
yeah that seems pretty bad to play on
your video well they're not exotic
they're on fire
very popular meme song um
so these guys have beautiful hair and
you know i love an element of danger in
my life as well
unfortunately i do i do know that yes
yeah
that's what you know so i've just been
really enchanted by these guys watch
this
and i want to do it and dan has been
saying it's not safe
it's not look at this bro this guy's
head is on fire and he's just sitting
there like nothing
he's cheesing he's laughing he's smiling
i'm sure these guys have safety protocol
you know i'm sure there's someone on
standby with the
uh-huh with that oh yeah fire
extinguisher
it's very official and safe you think
that's a smile of joy or
or like i might die right now look at
him he's like oh boy
that looks like joy yeah just some
homies having a good time yeah
just lighten up your homies
well anyway i do love their hair so we
have been fortunate enough to find
someone here in la
to perform a fire haircut for me
and i have that here for you guys now so
please enjoy
me getting a fire haircut yo
this is sick dude these barbers are yo
dan check this out
these barbers are cutting hair with fire
oh yeah
yeah we watch this on the pod i can't
get over how
unsafe and insane it is totally crazy
what the hell but i actually i want to i
do want to try it
for the show yeah you look at this guy
this guy's a professional for his shirt
i wanted this guy to come cut my hair
for real
no you think i'm not serious are you we
can't do that
what do you mean let's find someone in
l.a to cut my hair with fire you're
gonna wind up looking like me dude
are you serious dan i don't know how
many ways i need to tell you this
i want to light my head on fire i can't
wait i can't let you do that this is
insane like these people are crazy
zach will you call it a fire barber for
me this is gonna be sick
this is gonna be sick what i want to do
is i want to prep your hair first
okay before the fire gets
hot this haircut is going to be the
hottest haircut you've ever seen
these are professionals do not try this
at home
yes these are professional fire benders
and um they're here to set me on fire
oh where i smell burning hair what are
we doing right now we are
cauterizing and healing the ends of your
hair
got it okay
he's dripping oh yeah no no not
[Music]
everything changed when the fire nation
attacked
how do you feel what are you feeling
here um
like good i need to create like some
connections
oh okay should i look at your eyes oh
just
yeah i'll look good yeah so all i need
you to do is just relax
do not think about anything just think
about yourself
keep concentrated looking inside
yourself now you can look at my eyes
okay and just trust me okay okay yes
[Music]
okay okay
okay all right yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i got you i got you are you okay here we
this was not safe not okay damn what the
[ __ ] was that
what do you mean your hair looks pretty
good you gotta you don't touch me okay
i'm sorry i'm sorry
you were in danger i was dude i was
doing such a it's my responsibility i
was unblocking my chocolates from the
whole season bro
i might as well don't block now there's
a little bit of you want me to get
why'd you do that i just inhaled more
[ __ ] listen man it's uh
just trying to keep things get the [ __ ]
away from me bro i'm sorry
[Applause]
i'll keep you safe
[Music]
dan [ __ ] it all up as usual i was
trying to vibe out with my fire hair
and dan wouldn't let me do it after
everything you know he still doesn't
trust me
so thanks dan shame
we love dan those guys were characters
man the guys who came and did the fire
haircut shout out to them
you remember their name their salon i
sure do
yeah give them a shout out i will shout
them out right now as soon as i bring up
my notes where i wrote you guys are in
the market for an entire haircut these
guys will take care of you
and it's a whole like a mind and body
experience with the chakras and the
shoulders and the touches and everything
yeah it was uh jr and jana
were the two and they run a salon over
in beverly
hills where they specialize in this kind
of stuff and um
yeah memes aside they they actually do
know what they're doing
uh they kind of explain to us that do
not try this at home don't try it at
home
a lot of the videos that you see online
they're doing it the wrong way it is
very dangerous but if you do it properly
it it it is a legitimate technique
apparently
yeah i want to say i want to watch a
bravo show about those two just
combining people on fire
i'd watch that yeah interesting they're
like they bicker
yeah it's awesome they're like cutting
my hair and bickering i was like holy
[ __ ] it's like a whole
entertainment package anyway so there
you go we finally can
lay the fire haircut meme to rest we've
done it
i wanted him to really light my head on
fire but they're like too serious
yeah they're like no they took their
craft racers i was like listen just
spray a bunch of [ __ ] fuel on my hair
and light me on fire
and they're like listen we ca that's not
safe and i was like what
what if all these people on the internet
doing i see this guy like he's got like
five feet of flame on his head he was
down to clown a little bit with the uh
where he was you know spraying the uh
hairspray through it to make it like a
giant flame
and everything yeah i think if the i
think if his girlfriend wasn't here i
could have got him to let me on fire
you keep saying that i don't know if
there are a couple they were a couple
okay i think so no they were a couple
they were calling each other babe and
stuff
that might just be like hairdresser talk
though no they're a couple okay fair
enough
but anyway i he was ready to light my
hair on fire but she was being too
professional
one other thing also before we move on
to the main topics here
poor boogie he sent in a roast
and it was never presented
and i was sending everyone thank yous
and i was like i see buggy sent one but
i didn't see it what happened dan well
yeah it's on me
we um cause i was getting so many videos
and if people remember
they were all in like a box with the
flames behind it and everything
and that's because i had to conform all
you know some of them were iphone videos
some of them for real cameras
all over the place with the formats and
everything so i had to conform
everything
to one spec and i did it as a big batch
and uh i don't know i just uh i missed
it
it's my my fault thanks dan yep
poor boogie was probably watching at
home like yeah i know i can't wait for
mine to show up
really bad and then we're like spy yeah
ian or
ethan messaged me it's just like what
happened to boogie
and you know as soon as you said it i
was just like oh my god what did happen
to boogie this
he must have thought like we just didn't
like his
and didn't show it i haven't seen it yet
by the way i didn't watch any of them
beforehand so here's boogies
late uh but uh not forgotten boogie go
ahead
better not be about my small [ __ ]
hands
what's up ladies and gentlemen of
youtube boogie2988 coming at your level
again through the power
of the internet and this is a quick
little birthday message for the one and
only
ethan klein and ethan i just want to
wish you a happy birthday uh
what else do you get for the man who has
everything
and deserves absolutely none of it i
mean i don't i don't necessarily believe
that but some people do believe that
because you have really bad judgment
calls i mean
ela was a good choice but then you you
did try to befriend trisha paytas
you let me be on your podcast three
times and yet you've only had bo burnham
on there once
i think it just comes down to my
self-control
something i clearly struggle with i
think you just don't have
good control when it comes to making
judgment calls i think you have less
control over your judgment calls than
you do your own face muscles
you once told me i inspired you to
follow in my footsteps
this doesn't feel right out of the
context of the roast it just feels like
he's being super mean to me then
like don't hold it against me this is a
good roast but now
i just feel like why am i watching this
guy just be super mean to me
i'm just sitting here minding my own
business okay go ahead boogie become the
successful youtuber you are today
well no one's saying you have to follow
my footsteps into obscurity ethan
stop [ __ ] up but even with your
recent bad decision making i have to say
you're still inspiring people like me
and wings of redemption and dark side
phil proving to us that even an
idiot can still be successful those are
deep cuts i didn't get
i'm assuming wings of redemption
dark side phil darkseid phil i know
that name i couldn't tell you who it is
though i'm not supposed to pause i'm
just gonna let him go yeah
and occasionally get laid at least long
enough to bring some kids into the world
all joking aside seriously though uh
happy birthday ethan
you are an inspiration to me and many
other people and you're not all bad at
decision making uh the h3 podcast one of
the smartest decisions you ever made
uh starting teddy fresh with ela one of
the smartest decisions
you've ever made and of course marrying
ela and starting a family with her
the smartest decision he's chill but
he's almost i feel like he's trying to
make a pass on my wife
all the things about great healing you
know you were complaining earlier that
there wasn't enough nice stuff
yeah he's just complaining he's
complimenting my wife
but boogie's trying to [ __ ] either
anyone could have made in that situation
so happy birthday my friend and let's
just hope ela doesn't have
good judgment either because i mean she
did marry you and if she ever
wises up and leaves you uh you're gonna
wish you had a prenup
trust me i speak from experience eli if
you ever i would not
ever first of all if we ever get
divorced which she deserves everything
she deserves everything
is that we don't need a prenup trust me
half is generous
i mean it's generous to me believe that
man
call me oh boogie at you you called it
you know you called it that was a good
roast it was a good one and i will also
say boogie's looking good
looks like he's keep losing weight yeah
he looks healthy
yeah i'm happy for him the only man on
the internet with more fupa than me
neck pooper than me those two names that
were mentioned are
creators that were banned for either
hateful speech or hateful conduct
i see that's what i thought but i didn't
want to say that and be wrong
but yeah oh they got banned for being
douches
or demonetized or permanent yeah death
to all of them
that's right wendy's gonna be us after
this episode if you keep playing that
sound
and i'm sorry boogie for the fat
football joke it's just
i felt like because we're in the
roasting it's okay it's roast mode
yeah you can thank you we'll reverse on
that all right out of roast mode
thank you boogie now out of roast mode
[Applause]
no more rose exiting roast mode
all right let's throw it to a quick
commercial break and when we come back
we're gonna be talking about austin
mcbroom
uh scamming the internet as usual and of
course trisha paytas
apology to yours truly ethan klein
time to take a short break thank you
rudy
kraken exchange
for the last 10 years kraken has been
one of the
best platforms for trading crypto online
and now with the new kraken app it's
easier than ever to buy and sell over 60
of the most popular
cryptocurrencies on the go 24 7. not
only that
jesse wellins that's the [ __ ] prank
guy yep
wait isn't his name similar wait his
name's super similar what is it
well his name is jesse but it's not well
what's his last name um
i i powell oh yeah pal you're right
[ __ ] sorry jesse you know how my brain
works
jesse powell friend of the show
is the owner of kraken this guy is a
solid
awesome dude friend of the show i would
not hesitate
to send everyone over to kraken.com
h3 or learn more search kraken in any of
the app stores
you can simply download the kraken app
connect your bank account and start
investing for as little as ten dollars
just one minute is all it takes to get
started and with the new kraken app
your portfolio is gonna be right in your
pocket wherever you go you can monitor
your investments track your winners and
losers keep tabs on your favorite
projects or view
the most traded cryptocurrency of the
day it's got all the features you need
with none of the complexity it's a
simpler way to invest in crypto
go to kraken.com h3 to learn more or
search kraken
in an app store brought to you by our
friend
jesse powell
not welland two different people
thank you kraken love you
[Music]
today's sponsor is public.com an
investing app where you can buy and sell
stocks follow investors and share ideas
public you know public sponsors great
creators that we love like defranco
emma chamberlain cody co graham steven
who we had a whole debate about last
time
yes we found out that love is a giant
fan of love
everyone said he's watched every video
of his gramps
steven shout out he's a mogul
and now h3 podcast public is the best
place to invest especially if you're
just getting started
the app is free and you can start with
as little as one dollar which is what
sets it apart from other investing apps
is that you can buy slices of shares
instead of the whole thing we've
discovered last time
you want to uh you want a whole stock of
like three thousand dollars
it's kind of a big barrier of entry if
you're just trying to have some fun
trying to learn you know you know it's
expensive to learn stocks if you have to
buy a whole share so it's a good place
to just
learn get comfortable and eventually
when you're ready to put some real money
in
uh to do that as well like i said you
can start with just one dollar
buy slices portions of stocks and they
don't sell your data or information to
third parties or market makers
like other investing apps [ __ ]
you'll get one free slice of a stock
when you go to public.com
h3h3 to download the public app
to get started today make sure to follow
me do we have a your phone there right
dan
yeah so you can follow me what's your uh
just that's word love
so with public you don't even need
to put in the money because you're
getting a free slice at public.com
h3 this is a great way to get involved
start
learning and get started once again make
sure to go to public.com
h3h3 to get a free stock slice link
is in the description thank you public
oh hey consolidating your credit card
debt never
felt so good with upstart
are you carrying a credit card balance
month after month you're not the only
one
high interest rates make it hard to pay
off your debt but
upstart can help join the thousands of
happy borrowers who made that final
payment
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple
fixed monthly payment boom
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income
employment history this means they can
offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five-minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front
up yeah up front yeah i thought they
were doing the play on words but
it's not up front
[Music]
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
oh find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
h3 that's upstart.com h3
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we
are the [ __ ] who sent them loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
slash h3 thank you
[Music]
okay welcome back um
so you know trisha put out an apology to
me
she put out a video called apology to
ethan
and i do want to comment on this i guess
uh i should
i should comment on it um
look
first of all let me say i appreciate the
apology i appreciate that she's
making an effort to make peace with us
which i think is important
you know it's it's nice
[Music]
so i appreciate that she apologized for
sharing our text messages
and uh she made a general apology
um she apologized to the crew
um look she she said in her video
i'm going to make this apology and ethan
doesn't have to accept it
it's not that i don't accept her apology
it's that i don't want to i don't want
to
like gloss over i just i don't want to
gloss over
too much what went down i mean
it's a lot for me to forgive this fast
because
this is a person who
i considered you know
family a close friend someone i trusted
someone that we were working together
with that i had a
very close relationship someone who i
was confiding in
and you know
[Music]
as much as i understand that she has
like conditions that make
you know processing emotions hard for
her
um this is somebody who
i perceived as
did she she honestly without mincing
words was trying to like
ruin my life to she was
saying everything she could to attack me
personally
to attack the business i mean she was
like
liking tweets that were saying i was a
racist
and you know these things really
and she's like and like the whole
disneyland thing and digging up all this
and like and her sister which i know was
her sister she put out that video but
like
that she doesn't her sister doesn't just
put out that video in a vacuum
that's the result of them all talking
about stuff and like
i feel like maybe maybe i'm reading too
into it but i feel like
that video her sister put out is the
product of like them all
circle jerking about what a piece of
[ __ ] i am right
she said that i'm a liar she said that i
lied about
her wanting to fire the crew she said i
lied about
her saying that uh she
i mean look trisha does this thing where
she goes
i never trisha never explicitly
said um i want to fire the crew
right what she did say is that
i only hire fans they're not
professionals she's not comfortable
being them
with them and if we're going to continue
friends we need a whole new
staff we need a whole new crew did you
say
um i want you to fire the crew
no but like you said everything you lit
you did say that without
explicitly saying i want to fire the
crew
you know did she say i sexually harassed
her no she didn't say that but she said
i was making everything sexual i was
making her beauty product sexual that i
she was saying that i intentionally
brought up this candle thing with her
family on the way to disneyland just to
get a rise of them
which to me is just so offensive bro
that's just a horrible thing to say like
you know and
ish i feel like she really tried her app
she
she tried to ruin my life my reputation
my business
and not only that there's there's been a
lot of
heavy emotions within the family because
obviously she's engaged to my
brother-in-law ila's brother
and this is fi far-reaching implications
with
with elo's whole family
and it's not been it's been very
difficult it's been very stressful
and um
it's nice that she's apologizing now
after trying to ruin my whole life
and you know if this is an apology to me
right it says apology to ethan this is
my apology
i watched the whole 40 minute video and
i watched all 10 mid roles
it's like do i have to watch 10 mid
roles to get my apology why do i have to
watch 10 miserables to get my apology
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven mid rolls
if this is an apology to me why do i
have to watch it on her youtube channel
with ten mid rolls
a phone call would have been nice
she has my number she knows that i'm
open to talk anytime she messed you know
what i mean
and she apologized to the crew she said
previously she doesn't have any of the
crew's
contact information i'm sorry but that's
not true
we're all in a group chat on whatsapp
she has everybody's phone number
she could have called them to apologize
they don't need to watch
11 mid roles to get their apology either
so do i appreciate her apology
yes it is nice and helpful just to clear
the air
but is it the most personal and
meaningful apology that i have to watch
it on our youtube channel with 11
minerals no
no it's not
you know frankly
i don't know it's like you know and she
she says stuff like you know i'm over
wanting an apology i have to move on i
don't i honestly don't know
i've this is someone who i've tried my
best in every conceivable way
to be to be loving and supportive and
gracious
and then like the minute things went
wrong this third time she she i know i
don't know she
she tried i really feel like she tried
to ruin my life
and the good thing for me
is because you know another thing she
says is well why did you post
that final episode if it made me look so
bad
first of all you guys can understand
trisha put out her video
before the final episode was even posted
publicly
and you know she's the one who told me
to post it we were talking about it
privately
and she was so convinced she was right
she's like put it up unedited and let's
see who's right i was like okay maybe
you're right maybe i'm dazzled
and so she told me to put it up she put
out her video saying
things were this way and so of course
i'm gonna put up the video so people can
have
the the uh the objective situation and
put
their own judgment from
and listen the only thing that saved me
from trisha trying to do everything to
ruin my life
is the fact that all of our fights and
confrontation were
put up unedited on frenemies because if
i was like you know what i'm going to
not air this to protect trisha
unfortunately
that gives trisha all the space she
needs to say well this is what happened
this is whatever happened happened
and then it's my word against her i
don't want to be in that situation with
my word versus her
the whole frenemies experiment was like
whatever happens happens and this is the
whole wild ride
so like i understand people being like
oh you shouldn't have posted it but if i
don't
post it and you guys can't see what
actually happened then
then she could say whatever the [ __ ] she
want and she tried she tried to say
whatever she wanted about me
so you know i'm glad she's apologized
you know again i appreciate that
but um
i need uh time before i can really
uh you know
move on from this or to come to some
understanding
from it because
i don't know i just think like
it's scary it scares me it scares me
because this is someone who i confide in
will consider friends and family and
someone who was
you know willing at the time of crisis
to go out publicly and say
anything about me and i frankly can't
i can't risk as much as i love and
respect trisha
and she's so talented entertaining and
all the great things about her
i can't risk having someone
close to me in my life who was willing
to just step
out into the public eye and say anything
about me
when things go a little south that's
just not something
that
that's just not something that uh i can
accept frankly
and you know we had fought before but
this obviously went to a new degree
where she's posting her text messages
she's saying i'm a liar i'm a
manipulator
and you know one thing that really upset
me was like her going
and amplifying people going put making
these
little things about like oh ethan's
racist or whatever stupid things i've
done in the past she's out there liking
those tweets and it's like
okay so so this is nothing to do with
our fight this is just you trying to
hurt me as much as possible i
understand this
and i understand that she was hurt and
she was confused
and you know she felt trapped but
i just can't bring that
i can't invite that back into my life i
can
um forever for myself for my business
for my family
um i don't know it was that whole thing
i cannot emphasize just how
much it hurt me on a personal level
and um i'm still recovering from it so
while i appreciate the apology
it would have been nice to get an
apology where i didn't have to watch 10
mid midrolls to get it
i don't know if that's too much to ask
and listen she can get out there and get
paid and do her thing and
make that paper you know i'm all about
that thing i always support trisha
doing her thing and getting paid but
like is this an apology to who is this
an apology to is it to me
it says apology to ethan i think it's to
me why don't you call me and give me an
apology
or send me a thoughtful email or met or
you know what i mean
because like
it's a lot of i don't know you know what
i'm saying
anyway listen i'm glad i'm glad she made
the apology though
in short and um
you know that's pretty much all i have
to say about it without
i don't want to you know that's just my
honest thoughts
you guys want i'm sure you guys wanted
to hear it it's
very public all this now so you know i'm
sure there's there'll be a time
and place where we can reconcile but i'm
not ready for that yet
and um
that's about it i mean that's that's i
don't know what more i have to say about
it
please buy a friend of mine's merch
coming out soon
i'm really [ __ ]
framie's merch is coming out in like a
week or two i really need you guys to
buy that [ __ ]
oh there was one funny thing i actually
wanted to to share
she managed to sneak in an attack on
gabby hannah during my apology
here you guys can enjoy this i thought
it was funny
cycle through people quickly and he's
obviously worked with the same crew so
this has nothing to do with him i don't
want people think that's where i'm going
with this
but people you know underpaid dancers um
there's youtubers
you know i know a guy youtuber that does
music videos and
doesn't pay his dancers at all and you
know there's just people who don't
respect the work that people put in or
people
like gabby yelling at the escape the
night crew because
they changed the schedule or didn't have
food for her when she even put in the
request you know it's like
tricia are you apologizing to me why are
we talking about gabby had not put a
good food request
listen ethan i am just i'm so sorry this
this apology is brought to you by
walmart
shop for less anyway ethan i was just
saying that i know i really [ __ ] up
and i just want to apologize for sending
your text message
this apology is brought to you by
king kong streaming now
oh
okay
this epis this anyway like i was saying
like can you imagine if i got a call and
then she had like 10 sponsors during our
call
hold on one sec uh listen
i i feel horrible about how everything
went down and uh
costco world market
on sale 15 off
july 4th sale anyway i was saying i'm
just really sorry
she's hustling though you know what i
mean you gotta you know everyone gotta
get that
on that paper on that paper chase you
know that five percent ain't gonna
[ __ ] fill itself up
he takes that five percent those coffers
ain't gonna fill themselves up
and listen you can't get mad that five
percent meme is way too fire to drop
there's no way i mean what
five percent means everything yeah this
is joe rogan's been saying that for
forever five percent means everything
you know so get that paper i guess
but it doesn't feel that genuine to me
that's all i'm saying okay peace and
love
um oh i also want to say we put out a
families today
wednesday we talked about my i asked my
mom to summarize the trisha paytas
versus gabby hannah beef it's the
spiciest beef on the internet currently
and so you know there were some
insensitive remarks made about trisha i
just want to say
that those that was filmed before we saw
this apology i that i knew it was posted
on that
i didn't know it was even posted on that
day until
later in that day after we had posted
the family so
i don't want it to seem like i was like
oh she apologized let's you know
so apologies to trisha for that you know
bad timing i guess
um i'll issue an apology to her with 20
minerals
smash that like button
kind of like the idea of just making an
apology with as much mid roles as
possible
can we just on this part put in a
mineral every minute
no no we shouldn't that is funny though
it's a funny idea yeah
and it would be like she apologized
specifically for
leaking all of our text messages which
is true that was a line that she crossed
where
when she started posting all of our text
messages i just texted her i said look
trisha
you're posting our private dms you know
this is a line
you're crossing that i i have to um
discontinue this conversation now
and pretty much ended communication at
that point because it's like
dude i mean if it's to that level then
it wasn't supposed to go to that level
we were friend with this we're not [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like there i
thought there was a level of trust
between us
where it was like we're not going to get
to that point where you start blasting
out all of our private messages and so
for me
i was like this is not i thought there
was something
sacred about our relationship where it
was gonna
it was it was able to withstand
the the storm that happens you know the
storms that happen in trisha's life
where
i thought we had built something more
kind of special
for that reason and so when she started
posting all the text messages i thought
like man
you know it really did end up in a place
that i really hoped it wouldn't
because that i don't know
uh
yeah it's uh it sucks i love that show
for enemies i loved it i loved it
and it meant so much to so many people
too that like it's
really hard to say goodbye to it it was
just it was a special beautiful thing
that i'll always cherish it was
just um
i'm you know i miss it already on
mondays every monday getting together
seeing tricia and moses and filming it's
like i miss it too and i'm sad it's over
but like
i just feel like it's not uh especially
with her being engaged to moses it's
just not
it's not healthy for the family seeing
the way that it ended
i just you know
but she so i was saying she apologized
for the text messages
that she she didn't apologize for saying
i lied about her wanting to fire the
crew
she didn't apologize about saying i lied
and manipulated and i'm
psychotic freak about the
saying her claiming that i sexually
harassed her by the way difference
between harassment and assault let's
make that clear
you know so i don't know i don't know
what really she's sorry i don't know how
much she's sorry for
she didn't really specifically say
she says that she she was expecting an
apology for me
she doesn't she got over it though she
let it go i don't know what she wants an
apology for i don't i would apologize if
i knew
i think she thinks that i lied about her
and i don't know how that's possible
anyway i don't i don't want to linger on
this too long i just want to acknowledge
it
i'm happy she apologized i'm grateful
it's nice that
we can kind of like just put this whole
thing to rest for now
and i need some time to recover to make
kind of like
i think what's most important is just in
the background to make things functional
for our families which is going to be
i'm not going to lie it's going to be
hard it is going to be hard
can you get a mid roll right there dan
like two in a row
you got it thank you that's all i don't
know what to say i don't
i don't know what to say i mean i
appreciate it i appreciate it
okay what can i say
you know
you know what i'm saying yeah i said it
all i think
you want to talk about austin mcbroom oh
yeah
oh yeah yo this guy austin mcbroom
is such a freaking scammer i hope this
guy goes to jail
this is the guy we did a content court
about him he's the ace family guy
he's the guy with the uh stop sound by
yeah we have a uh a fun little uh edit
that
a b made if you want to show that real
quick oh is this a reminder i believe so
yeah yeah uh-oh
no yeah he was he
was flooding his whole neighbor's yard
with this he put a jet ski in his pool
and what you can see there's like a
mudslide occurring
and his neighbors are screaming stop you
can hear it in his video you can hear it
down it's
the guy is just the worst
[Music]
[Applause]
i love the dual perspective it's
powerful
dude why are you doing that it's like
he's trying to kick water off
i mean he is he's trying to kick water
out
but there was like a whole csi analysis
on this where you can see the neighbor
screaming stop
and then in the video you can also hear
him from the ace family's perspective
screaming stop
so they obviously heard him and chose to
ignore
go ahead yeah that's from the ace family
video
but we talked about he did this uh he
did this huge
basketball event where he said he was
going to be donating it to charity
twice twice it he got all these big
creators it turns out
he ended up just donating what like 50
000 well the first time
he promised that he would be donating a
hundred thousand dollars to
the charity of his own choosing uh which
is usually how these things go right
because and then and then ended up
donating
75 000 instead with no explanation for
why it was the lower amount and by the
way the giant check that they have there
just says
ace ch ace family charity of choice
so at the time of the event they never
even supplied
so we don't even know we really have no
idea if that money ever went to any
charity
so maybe he did maybe it didn't he
marketed this as a big
charity event he sold out the staples
center we calculate based on our biggest
uh our best estimate that they
potentially made
around six hundred thousand dollars no
i'm sorry that's the first event and
that one was at the galen center which
is
at uh usc the second event they upped
the ante to the staples center
and that was the one by our best
estimate they actually sold about
1.5 million in ticket revenue based off
the ticket price so the first
time at that he he potentially made six
hundred thousand
we had we did a whole crunching numbers
the second time we estimate he made
about 1.5 million
and then the second one was also a
charity event he donated apparently
uh a hundred thousand dollars today
split with chris
brown who i don't know why the [ __ ] he
was involved
because they like to associate with the
best people
that's what we do yeah exactly
you talk about wanting that clout and i
mean it was 1.5 million in ticket rev
obviously renting on the staples center
everything was very expensive but even
we deducted we deducted we deducted
about a 500 000 for all the costs so
they still probably walked away with
about a cool million
for the event while donating 50k and
we apparently like ace family charity
it's just this this was just a huge
rocket
and we tried our we did our due
diligence to figure this out and i'll
speak out of turn
this guy there's no evidence count that
contradicts
the notion that they pocketed a shitload
of [ __ ] money i mean everything about
the event was marketed
as a charity event which generally when
you go to a charity event
the money that you're paying for a
ticket you would assume is going to
change
all profit goes to charity that's a fair
assumption that so this
he donated a hundred thousand fifty
thousand of it came from chris brown
i [ __ ] gave a hundred thousand
dollars out on twitter and i didn't have
to sell one point
you know two million dollars of revenue
and [ __ ] on [ __ ] at staples
ace family has a lot more subscribers
than us i'm pretty sure ace family's got
more money than me
yes not to do my own horn but i but you
know what i'm saying like
this guy is a true piece of [ __ ] so when
the tick tock
verse um took talk versus
youtube boxing event that recently went
down
hosted by the ace family i was like oh
boy someone's gonna get burned here
someone's gonna get burned here oh
there's this other way
i'm getting ahead of myself he bro he
did how i became a millionaire
dude first of all anytime someone says
how i became a millionaire you just know
by ripping people off like you who paid
for this course yes
that's like the only conclusion you
could draw from that here
ace family launches how i became a
millionaire which claims to teach how to
become millionaires on social media
for fifty dollars per month
what's the tip you're just a social
media dude and then you steal money from
people and
do fake social events what's the tip
i just don't understand jake paul tried
to do this [ __ ] too like guys
there's no secret there's no [ __ ]
secret on how to do become a millionaire
and if you're like
i don't care about literally scamming
anybody
yeah that's good advice i guess if you
just want to make money and that that
would be the honest advice from him
this is where it all started
now this is my home my dream home
and i've been very blessed and fortunate
to have done it through the power of
social media
which is why i'm here today to teach all
of you the secrets to social media
this is and to help you accomplish your
nightmare in this program i'll be
teaching four courses
the first course is how to grow your
soul so rich you can't get a [ __ ]
decent audio equipment it's like
this there's like wind there's wench
i think they just shot it on a phone
seemingly high budget [ __ ] dude yeah
social media platforms the second course
is how to make money from social media
the third course is how to start a
business he's like okay once you start
getting views on youtube you want to
enable adsense this is huge guys this is
how you make money on youtube
what do you what advice can you offer to
the world you're you are scamming people
and the last course is how to grow your
business in order to be able to have
access to all of you guys
you must join now you only have 24 hours
here in my garage totally i don't know
what else to say
i guess the next time i'll see you guys
we'll be inside the program
oh my god dude this is such a wannabe
[Music]
this is so embarrassing
by the way this is the second of this
type of scam that he ran he already had
one called the
the ace club yeah what was that because
i remember him making a video being like
yo i'm really sorry
yeah that you guys all lost your money
it wasn't my fault though yeah he he
blamed it all on a partner
uh that he was involved with and and to
be totally fair to him
although you know based off of what we
know i don't know if this is true or not
but he claims he refunded everybody for
that first
failed uh venture into um mentorship i
guess
here's him talking about the ace club
another scam hero you guys have asked
what has happened with the ace club when
we were doing exclusive comments with
the ace club
um and unfortunately the people that we
partnered with
in that adventure somehow
these adventures i don't really like to
go ahead
you could say negatively but of course
they just weren't good partners
no why'd you partner with them
he's like damn it's just somehow
whenever i partner with someone or do
any kind of venture
you guys just lose your money and get
nothing it's just such a crazy
coincidence bro
idiot unfortunately scamming us
he's the one that got scammed um and
it kind of like hurt us in a way because
in reality like you guys got scammed
um your fans
your audience that trusts you got
scammed
here he is saying i'm a scammer you guys
got scammed
well he's not these other faceless
people who i'm not naming
but because i don't like to talk
negatively but they scam you i don't
want to talk negatively about these
people but
they're [ __ ] scammers and they ruined
and they stole your money they stole
your money and don't come after me
because i know whoever that's like
possible i partnered with nothing to do
with the ace club
he's like hey i vetted them i partner
with them
they stole your money super unfortunate
they were bad partners
it's it's kind of like what he did with
that guy who he wanted to collab with
for the headbands right he ripped him
off and he goes oh this guy's just a
clown goblin yeah everyone's a clout
goblin
or
bro i don't know who watches this [ __ ]
who buys this [ __ ]
this guy is the lowest of the low man
wait till you hear what happened with
this boxing event because this is too
good i think you might be going to jail
i really think he might be going to jail
from this new one and he should be
this is outrageous um like
the way this side you got to pull that
you guys got scammed zach
right here oh okay um
like but they just weren't good partners
um they end up unfortunately scamming us
uh right here hold on and it kind of
like hurt us
in a way because it hurt us in a way
like not that much we didn't lose money
we gained we made we
made it it hurt us in a way
not not in one way but not in other ways
in reality like you guys got scammed
yeah um like
paul you guys got scammed that's huge
okay i'll pull it
the way the site was built it wasn't
built to the degree that we needed to be
because obviously the ace family
is one strong ass army oh yeah and come
to find out the site
wasn't built well at all it's almost
like you have a responsibility to make
sure the [ __ ] that you're
[ __ ] shilling to your fans should not
be a scam bro so you guys didn't get
the value and the quality you guys
should have got and that's why we were
upset
and unfortunately we had to stop the
the ace club by the way this is a super
official apology
15 000 viewers on his instagram live
this is like definitely the place to
acknowledge
you scammed your fans and which we
refunded everybody so we
appreciate all you guys for
understanding that we had to stop that
so he does say that they refunded well
then how did they get scammed if they
got their money back
yeah something's not adding up here yeah
well anyway but this brings us to the
modern day
this guy has basically a long career of
scamming people
so now the box the youtube boxing thing
is this big uh
it's a big cash cow let's be honest
estimates say logan paul made like 10 20
million off his fight with mayweather
uh jake paul who knows i don't know
trailer lies about their numbers so who
knows
how light should they what do i know
i know this guy ran when ryan cavanaugh
is a piece of [ __ ]
i mean he's run a ponzi scheme of light
should be from his partner so
of course the guy is capable of flying
as we all are but
he lies allegedly according to his
partner
ryan cavanaugh owner of trailer ryan
cavanaugh
look him up owner of trailer scammer
allegedly
peace and love according to his partner
this guy suing me by the way
was i talking about austin mcbroom
and uh yeah the uh the fight the big
[ __ ]
you guys probably saw all this [ __ ] like
uh bryce
hall who was fighting austin and there
was all these
under cars of tick tockers and youtubes
ksi's brother was in it
bryce hall famously was going like i get
five million dollars just to step in the
ring
and another five percent pay-per-view
uh you know and a million dollar
knockout bonus
he was taking that five percent five
percent difference is astronomical
it always comes back to the five percent
five percent means everything
and so now fast forward like one week
later none of the fighters have been
paid
nobody's been paid nobody knows what's
going on
apparently they were planning on selling
five hundred thousand
subscriptions they only sold a hundred
thousand they've made
nowhere near enough money
to cover all these outlandish um
guarantees here is um
one of the guys talking about it
did you see what he was tweeting like
three months ago about the fight he was
like no one's gonna get paid
but did the fighters not get paid nope
nobody got paid fighters didn't get paid
artists didn't get paid
no no one got paid i'm pretty sure so
bryce hall didn't get any money
uh not not from what i know
and i haven't got to actually talk to
bryce i guess yet but since after the
fight has happened
all the reports have said that no one's
gotten paid no [ __ ]
they've gotten their signing bonuses
which was like probably 100k
50k depending on the fighter none of the
other monies come
through are they telling them when they
will so that's that friend of the show
dave porque boy shout out friend of the
show
the only man who loves pizza as much as
me i feel like we could be friends in a
parallel universe
me and pork
he's jewish right we determined that uh
maybe i think he is let's google that
not enough for you guys to be buddies
dave portnoy jewish he has no pizza
experience
he is jewish well there you go we could
be two pals sharing of size
in another life eh maybe in another life
so now it comes out
that austin book broom ace family
scammer
death noodle shout out
on the registered paperwork this is the
company that put on the show
social gloves wait for this
owner and ceo austin mcbroom
this [ __ ] of course and of
course he does
that's what i believe i assumed he was
running that
he was behind this whole thing you know
now uh just to
point this out uh you you likely know a
lot more about this so maybe this
isn't that pertinent but that is a
trademark filing not
a like registration of an llc or an s
corp or anything yeah
i don't know how much of a difference
that makes but i just that isn't
actually
proof positive that he owns if he
personally is filing for
the social gloves trademark right he
owns
the company right okay i thought he
wouldn't be able to own it
right yeah okay yeah that makes sense he
can't just i just when i was looking at
it
i noticed nike right no that totally
makes sense
just when i was looking it over i saw
that this was trademark stuff and not
it's a clue it's a very powerful clue
yeah i agree it's a very
powerful clue that he owns this [ __ ]
which he never just says and he says
he's the ceo or does it
yeah it says signatories position ceo
he's the ceo of the ace hat company
incorporated right he's the ceo of the
company that's dude let's not [ __ ]
around he's filing i kill you
yeah he owns it i know what you're
saying we just don't want any other
lawsuits
yeah exactly listen at this point
i actually unlike uh keemstar do have a
team of lawyers at this point
right you really do i got lawyers on
retainers on retainers
i mean sued
let me know because i got a [ __ ]
files on top of files to swing back
exactly god you're fast with that zach
um yeah he
he put out a dude he's such a he put out
that tweak being like
i can't wait to talk about it where's
that one oh you know what jake paul put
out a bomb tweet i'm not even gonna hate
on this one
i know i saw this and i sent it to you i
was like this is powerful tweet
and i only have seven thousand likes i
think this is a shame you know i've i'm
he blocked me otherwise i'd retweet this
jake's engagement on twitter is really
really low i i don't know
if he's shadow banned or something but
like that's not a thing his tweets just
suck
okay fair enough like like for his for
his popularity and size he he doesn't
get that many likes
uh generally it's kind of surprising but
yeah this was a fire tweet gotta hand it
to him
um he said spot the difference austin
mcbroom and the fire festival guy
i think you're spot on dude that's not
fraud
the only difference is that the fire
festival guy actually thought he could
pull it off by some deluded weird thing
i'll send you straight up i'm scamming
people i would call that uh
false advertising yeah would you agree
with that austin false advertising or
fraud
that's not fraud okay maybe it is in
this case we'll find out
dude i hope he goes to jail dude the
thing is he didn't just rip off
youtubers he ripped off like huge
musicians like there was big musical
acts there wasn't there
uh dj khaled right oh cal
ain't gonna get ripped off boy he stays
winning another one
dude kyle had a great line he goes you
know why i'm not been losing weight
he says because i don't lose i only win
i was like i like that here's austin
trying to get ahead
of it wait till you read this [ __ ]
before people start any rumors we are
working tirelessly to verify the
financial results of social
gloves event we have hired a leading
accounting firm
you mean a bankruptcy attorney
as well as a first class forensic
auditor
you mean because you're being sued
already by people like dj khaled
to make sure all of the amounts are
properly accounted for
that doesn't mean anything bro that
means you're in [ __ ]
dude you have a forensic auditor
that means you're in [ __ ] trouble
our sincere hope is to pay every fighter
and every talent who participated
it's their hope to pay every fighter
yeah they're
between the lines here guys and by the
way another great place to make a
statement in an instagram story
on the social gloves page by the way
right which has like no followers at all
super transparent
i mean even just the fact that he was
the headline fighter an event that he
owned without disclosing that like just
from the
like people were betting on this in
vegas and stuff right like isn't that a
big deal
um does that doesn't matter that he like
owns it without
anybody knowing that and he's like the
headline event
um i don't maybe not i don't know i
don't know
my eyebrow too if it's like cs go lotto
where they control the software then
but right i don't think it's
uh yeah i guess illegal if he was uh
purposely uh throwing the fight or i
guess in this case bryce doesn't matter
you can do that anyway right
our sincere hope is to pay every fighter
and every talent who participated in
this spectacular event
in a reasonable time frame please
continue to send us your receipts
as it assists and verifying the total
amount or
you're asking people to send in their
receipts
sorry what bro they're literally saying
send us your receipts
who the viewers are yeah pete this is an
instagram story from social gloves
they're saying if you bought this thing
send us your [ __ ] receipt so we can
verify the total amount earned i'm sorry
what just watching my algorithms get
crushed
i had i read that somehow my eyes just
like
went right over that without realizing
how insane yeah that seems to me some
kind of accounting scheme where they're
going to be like
we only collected these many receipts
that shows that we only sold 50 like
this is how they sold the receipts they
sold the tickets digitally like what do
you
mean we don't know how many tickets they
sold this is amazing please continue to
send us your receipts
as it assists in verifying the total
amounts earned
the [ __ ] they sound so organized
somehow this is even crazier than i
thought that's not fraud
austin mcbroom needs to get hooked up
with jaw rule i would call that uh
false advertising i'd love to see dr
roll and awesome and broom put it on an
event
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this [ __ ] we got to think how to dig
ourselves out of this send us your
receipts
we got we have forensic auditors
dude yeah i imagine also mcbroom at a
big table with all these receipts
he's got the he's got the bookie hat the
little visor and he's just like he's
smoking a cigar
just working late into the night it's
his sincere hope that everyone will get
paid
sincerely he hopes that everybody's
going to get paid oh here's
no it's not fraud you're going to get
paid inshallah
do you guys say clout
he's got plenty of that here's austin
this is his statement why does he care
if he doesn't own the company by the way
hundred thousand people ppv buys his cap
only the haters want to believe that
if anything these people who are
scamming which isn't social gloves
aka me are basically say and by the way
send in your receipts we need those to
keep tally of the sales are basically
saying all of us fighters fans base
ain't [ __ ] oh yeah now he's trying to be
like oh no they're attacking you the
fans
right they're saying they're saying our
fan base ain't [ __ ]
this is an attack on our fans we all
know social gloss put on one of the
biggest social media events in history
the real numbers will come out soon
still waiting
also instagram story just know social
gloves weren't the ones who collected
ppv
sales sorry what don't forget how you
watched it i don't know what that means
he's
claiming piracy i mean welcome to i mean
that's just that's the way it goes but
yeah i mean he's probably trying to
shift blame
to his partner right
sorry you guys got scammed man that was
a bad part because i'm sure social glove
is just the shell company that he set up
so i'm sure they're not equipped to
actually do the ticket sale so they
probably partnered with
you know ticketmaster whatever oh this
is interesting who who added this
the owner of socialglove's trademark is
ace hat's collection the ceo of asap's
collection is of course ace families
also mcbroom
and wife catherine is listed as
secretary
right we covered that's what we just
looked at yeah but also in that last
link
uh there's another instagram story
following that one from austin it says
uh just wait till i can actually speak
about oh where's that i don't see it
here
it's the link before the one you're just
looking at the highlighted highlight for
me please
it's highlighted isn't this what i
clicked
and then it's to the right it's not it's
three phones i see thank you
yeah he says uh just wait till i can
actually speak about it
okay dude i'm sure that's gonna so i
know if you're a woman
who would love this he's trying to get
people to fight tana i don't care
probably you're just you're a scammer
dude
so the rumor has it they're they're
getting declaring bankruptcy and
nobody's gonna get paid is there any uh
update on if they're declaring
bankruptcy it wasn't as of this morning
uh
i mean this is an evolving situation so
um
they're definitely declaring bankruptcy
i mean it seems uh yeah it's
like uh likely outcome of this are the
rumors from the fighters and everything
is that there
gotta be the cleric bankruptcy bye bye
which is just [ __ ] amazing
so austin mcbroom might be the worst
person on the internet
and he's a total scammer and he probably
might hopefully be going to jail
yeah all the uh news articles that pop
up in regards to the uh
bankruptcy thing are from two days ago
so there hasn't really been an update
what's going on with the ace family
channel like who the [ __ ] is supporting
these
actual human pieces of [ __ ] i mean i
kind of feel
a pain of sympathy for them i think you
know a lot of people just get uh very
enamored with these
sort of god they really families that
that project this picturesque life and
they
you know they they idolize them because
they represent something that they
hope to achieve someday i think um but
just they're obviously such shitty
people look how they use their kids too
boy i know
everything is with the kids i think it's
a theme song
oh wow this has like full like ratio
this has almost no dislikes
no i mean their fans are the ace he's
not wrong the ace family
is strong they are strong out there what
are you saying
i'm just saying i think it's a theme
song it's so catchy that's why they got
this
oh let me hear it their kid's name is
steel
yes indeed that's sorry i don't know
ea it's not spelled like stealing but
obviously because that's one that's his
favorite things
wouldn't be surprised if he named his
kid steel like with s-t-e-a-l
yeah i gotcha
hi this is my son steele and uh fraud
we didn't move into his house for no
reason this is my son
uh jod roll steel
fraud and fire festival i've been trying
to think of a pun for
the broom sweeping it under the rug
again oh
austin's
yeah i see it's tricky yeah somebody in
the comments will get a good one yeah
please let me know because it's been
driving me insane
austin mcbroom austin mc riding the
broom out of here
that's a female would be a witch uh he
could be a warlock
austin mc using a broom to sweep his
cell
do you have to sleep yourself probably i
don't know maybe the broom sweeps it
under the rug again
did i already say that i mean very
pretty good
it's pretty good it's not bad there's a
perfect there's a perfect one out there
and somebody's gonna nail it in the
comments
i just think he's such a shitty person
and so transparently awful
the way that they just parade their
family around
and it's so fake these people are so
miserable they hate each other he's
always cheating on her like every week
it's like
awesome boobs cheating on his wife and i
mean who is buying this [ __ ] man who
well the wife is apparently because she
always defends him
well yeah because they're like you know
they're in deep together yeah
they hate each other bro i [ __ ] bet
i bet on that boy
yeah the fact that they have kids and
they exploit them
makes it a little less funny
unfortunately like if it was just the
two of them you know those kids aren't
gonna see a dime either
yeah probably not nope yeah there's no
like no way yeah
those kids will not see a dime i
guarantee you
you'll be in jail and they'll be like
what happened dude
hi my name's steele and um
[Music]
and my dad's in jail for fraud
hi my name's steel fraud fire fest
first medal last
oh you want to know something great
definitely david dobrik put out a new
vlog
this is my buddy you know he he we
talked about this he like [ __ ] up his
friend's
eye and like made him lose vision in his
eye
and his new videos him paying for his
friend's medical expenses for a video
i'm like bro haven't you been rich
forever
like you [ __ ] this guy's eye up when
you were a kid and now you're waiting to
pay for it now that you're doing a vlog
and you like need
sympathy like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna throw the emotional in there
i mean come on bro this he should have
paid for his eye surgery long ago this
guy's walking around blind to one eye
david's like i'm going to need you one
day to win sympathy back go ahead abe i
dare you to sin for david
no no no i'm saying is it the same
friend are you mixing up
jeff well how many people did he [ __ ] up
no
no not jeff he told a story when he
threw a pine cone at his friend yeah
they hit him in the eye he lost vision
he got like bear you got to like infect
right
right right i'm assuming it's him i
don't know how many people's eye he's
[ __ ] up
he's racking up no it is it's definitely
his friend i recognize him yeah
yeah am i the only one that finds this a
little [ __ ]
he's been rich he just bought a 10
million dollar house like a year ago
and he's like i've been waiting till i
got into [ __ ]
to pay for your eye surgery you blind
[ __ ] loser
so that i can exploit you i mean i don't
know
what is it a good chance he probably he
should have fixed his eye years ago
yeah i mean years ago david's been rich
for a long time
apparently it was only like sixty
thousand dollars to him he says a lot of
money but like
he's he's got money how is this
no it's just ridiculous
yeah i mean i feel like there's a good
chance it wasn't even
it's probably not his idea is he's got a
crisis management firm
because his well that's even got trashed
and they were like what can we do
that's even worse because he's like
listen i didn't really want to fix your
[ __ ] eye
but now that people are talking about it
right
i mean that's dipping deep into
speculation he he
you know maybe he did once let's watch a
second
i can't tell if that's the video or if
that's dude the laughter
i feel like i feel like he's since his
return he's amped it up
if anything this video is like out of
control the level of laughter going on
wait is that the video or sound bite
that's the
that's the video that's a video are you
kidding me
dude you're so annoying
i have only laughed that hard once in my
life is when like a turkish fire guy
lit someone else on fire he was a fire
safety guy and he lit someone else on
fire on an accident
this is the only time i've laughed that
hard
that's that front of me is ending joy
what is so
funny
these are the sounds of hell bro if
there's a hell speakers are piping in
that laughter boy
nonstop guaranteed that is the sounds of
my mind
that was keemstar
there's no video it's just them laughing
i don't know what's happening
oh they pranked them jesus they must
have like tied his grandma up or
something but like you're my
grandma got assaulted
oh such a good prank
your grandma got kidnapped by isis she's
about to be headed
they had to like rush and clean their
dude
i don't know man people are watching
awesome mcbroom people are watching that
i got a problem with the internet
and you know what makes it even better
guess who sponsored that video
who pray tell me [ __ ] trailer
trailer by the way david the only
company that would touch him with a
10-foot pole
right now is trailer trailer
ryan cavanaugh the people that are suing
me for my expression of free speech
david dobrik who literally just who like
filmed someone being
essayed and put it online
trailers like this is a good time to get
a deal it's almost like trilla's trying
to make a statement ryan cavanaugh tell
me what's up
you you're sponsoring jake paul new york
times you know
pretty clear allegations on that one r
word
written new york times credible paper
got your hat
and then david dobrik it's like ryan
kevin are you trying to make a statement
that you support
essayists what did ryan cavanaugh
allegedly do again i can't recall oh so
ryan cavanaugh he's the owner of triller
he was the ceo of like a big uh i forget
the name of it but he like they went
bank like super bang the relativity
media maybe
yeah relatively super bankrupt and then
he like
got triller involved and like he was
accused of running a ponzi scheme
oh my god he's got a really dark history
i've read this online this is not me
saying this right this is all allegedly
who was it that accused him of running a
ponzi scheme it was his ex-partner oh
he probably knew him pretty well oh yeah
this ryan cavanaugh's a piece of [ __ ]
and so of course he would uh support
david dobrik and jake paul it's like
he's trying to make a statement
triller's such a [ __ ] app dude he linked
it
dude trailer such a ghost down this app
is dog [ __ ] even if you go to their
home page like the videos on the home
page have like no views
600 likes this is what's on the home
page
and they're paying all these people too
it's pathetic
60 likes this was on the home page
such a [ __ ] shitty app i personally
based on my usage of trailer gave it one
star on the app store just because
i think it's a horrible app right after
you used it for a couple hours
yeah no i tried it and i gave it one
star right because it's run by horrible
people ryan kavanagh who's kind of the
worst
i'm gonna i'm planning on talking more
about the lawsuit i'm waiting for the
right time that's coming up soon but
he's a horrible person
and um the app is horrible i mean it's
just horrible maybe our viewers should
download the app themselves
try it around for a couple hours and you
know
leave a review based off of their
experience on the app yeah
yeah give it an honest review give it a
give it a time
you know give it your honest take i give
it one stars based on my experience
right that's your experience your
mileage may vary you may enjoy it more
yes but i like i said i personally be
just because of ryan kavanagh the guy
who owns it and i didn't like it
i gave it one star on the app store
because it's just awful
what is this 125 likes is their homepage
just place a ghost down
there's nobody there i gave it one star
that's what it deserves personally but
you give whatever you
you rate it what you think they sponsor
david dobrik
sponsor jake paul imagine being so
shitty that jake paul leaves you
that's a one-star app right he's out
trailer is a one-star app
in your opinion in fact i want you know
what i think i should do i should
frame my one-star rating of trailer and
put it behind me
just to say like listen i think triller
is a one-star app
right and i don't think people should
use it specifically because the owner
ryan cavanaugh is
such a nasty piece of [ __ ] that's the
one that
whose business partner said that he ran
a ponzi scheme a legend ryan cavanaugh
that's ryan cavanaugh what was his name
again
ryan cavanaugh's business partner
alleged he runs
ron a ponzi scheme if you believe that
it's hard to believe i don't know if i
believe it or not i'll have to do my own
research on that yeah do your own
research
you know what ryan here ryan kavanagh i
believe it unless his ex partner was
austin mcbroom but if it wasn't austin
then i i believe in
interesting well hold on let me do my
own research now on the show ryan
cavanaugh
oh here it is oh my god huh that link
was purple
variety.com
ryan kavanagh accused by ex-partner of
running a ponzi scheme
what a shitty dude who runs a one-star
app variety that's
one of the two major trade papers in the
entertainment industry they're
very reputable huge name yeah
they go right kavanaugh is again in
broader in a legal battle man this guy's
litigious he's suing me
yeah he's being sued for fraud
dude ryan kavanagh isn't brought in a
legal battle as the former ceo of
entertainment stock exchange
former ceo and has sue wait i'm confused
is again
as the former ceo of an entertainment
exhaustion what i'm is the tense weird
in the sentence
has sued him for fraud and accused him
of running a ponzi scheme that's strong
wow unbelievable elon spar filed a suit
in los angeles superior court on
thursday alleging that kavanaugh
persuaded him
to go into business together under false
pretenses wow
shady as [ __ ] and you know i heard this
guy's looking to
uh go public with triller that would be
a horrible idea for people to invest in
trailer
i you know what would be a good idea to
short trailer
i'm so confident that they're well
they're not on the market yet
but like and this is not financial
advice ethan is not a financial advisor
no of course not but i might actually be
interested in
shorting triller because you can
actually make money from
businesses failing right going to the
moon baby
trailers going to the dirt baby
i just bought 39 million shares of
safe moon but anyway this guy ryan
cavanaugh he's on twitter by the way
what's his name
i follow him oh do you yeah no i
followed him because i just curious what
he's up to here let me look it up oh no
ryan kavanaugh is it just it's just ryan
cavanaugh
let me see ryan kevin i mean he's a
public
figure ponzi scheme oh whoops frank
having a ponzi scheme you don't want
that showing up next to his name
as the owner of trailer here he is yeah
ryan kavanagh just ryan kevin on twitter
huh there he is here he is scheme i've
just already ran a ponzi scheme
and variety by his ex-partner
yeah here he is ryan cavanaugh he's got
a website let's look at it
ryan kavanagh there he is serious guy
he's a film and tv producer entrepreneur
and ponzi scheme enthusiast wait no
sorry that was what his ex-partner said
alleged no it's not alleged his
ex-partner did say that well he made the
allegation yeah he said he was doing the
ponzi scheme right
that's enough he was making an
allegation but
okay you get the idea he's a
philanthropist i'd like to know who
[ __ ]
you know what kind of philanthropy he'll
be running when i short triller
he's going to be running philanthropy to
everybody who shorts trailer
that's free money
yeah learn more maybe we'll open the
court filing of him being suited for
running on ponzi's game
no
carrie is trying to look like he's
involved
right it looks like he's trying to he's
doing the producer thing yeah he
and you know uh what's his [ __ ] name
kevin uh some
kevin costner kevin costa is like dude
come on don't lean so [ __ ] close to
me stink
this guy gives me serious pig vomit
vibes
like from howard stern his producer he
hated he says you look he looks like a
pig and he makes me want to vomit god
big vomit he's an entrepreneur
well yeah i mean he's running upon does
running a ponzi scheme count as
entrepreneurial ship
yeah that might be in reference to
relativity media
perhaps it's unclear though
he doesn't actually specify let's see
what kind of philanthropy he does
he has uh he's been donating i donate
too i know what the [ __ ] you want from
me
wouldn't put philanthropists in my bio
[Music]
okay cool dude
anyway this is twitter one star
i don't think you can rate people's
twitter i rate him
oh he's definitely a one star person
anyway elon spar
listen guys this guy is [ __ ] with my
life this guy is suing me
he's [ __ ] with my life over some
[ __ ] i can't wait to talk about
literally for free speech fair you
saying his fight
sucked which it did jake paul versus ben
astrid so this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
elon and well that's just my that's just
my opinion his partner thinks his
partner is suing it for running a ponzi
scheme
elon spar filed suit in los angeles
superior court on thursday alleging that
kavanaugh persuaded him
to go into business under false pretense
while working at cantor fitzgerald spar
had developed an idea for stock exchange
which buyers could take equity and film
projects
in 2018 kavanaugh fresh from the second
bankruptcy of revelativity media
sounds like a stellar ceo i'm sure that
trailer's in good hands
told spar he had a six million dollar
commitment to invest in the project
according to the lawsuit kavanaugh also
claimed to have hundreds of millions of
dollars in commitment to finance a slate
of films under his new company proxima
media spark came to discover that that
was not true the suit alleges that's
literally what the fire festival guy did
very similar very similar it had
virtually no capital he said
it had no viable financial commitment
certainly nothing approaching the
magnitude of what was presented
over time as kavanaugh withdrew and
replaced one funding proposal
after another and each of his lives
exposed it became apparent to spar
that kavanaugh was operating up proxima
and its related entities
as essentially a ponzi scheme using
meager new investment capital to satisfy
old debts
diverting corporate funds for personal
use oof
instead of paying his employ oh yeah
he's hitting that mario
instead of paying his employees and
contractors and manipulating the
corporate books
to uh and records to conceal his misrep
this guy should be in jail by the sound
of it
shouldn't be suing me you should be in
jail when was this
uh article like how long ago this is
from 2019
june 7th so that's probably still
working its way through the courts huh
oh yeah
interesting you might need a little
cheddar from elsewhere
oh i'm sure
yeah that's super shady dude that's what
varieties bro
that's crazy so david dobrik huh
so he sponsored david dobrik controller
yeah david dobrik apparently
and then that's the other thing david
the david the generous soul
who [ __ ] this guy's eye up made him
blind in an eye is now giving him sixty
thousand dollars from trailer he
couldn't even dish it out of his own
[ __ ] pockets
i think the money is actually from some
charity or something so he pockets the
trailer money
yeah i don't think the triller money
goes he never explicitly says that
the check is from trailer he says it's
from me basically where's the trill
apart he just is like i
on trailer guys called follow my
checklist uh ariana
healthcare foundation a foundation that
helps people who cannot afford
surgery oh so he didn't even [ __ ] pay
a dime for this friend
anyway trillo's sponsoring him so good
luck to david on trailer i'm sure that
would be going
really good missed the mark with that
one
you guys want to do this compliment
battle to close it up not really
how long we've been going about uh 100
minutes
hour hour 40.
it's late i guess we should just lock it
up did we really have a full show it
didn't feel like it
uh yeah i mean my clock said an hour
in six minutes and plus the
33 minutes of the beginning and then
we're gonna do ads too so
it'll be we didn't have a true um off
the rails because we
we didn't have one of these uh sharing
story segments which we all love
we were gonna do a compliment battle but
we'll do that next
yeah next week let's do it next time but
the it's really got a really
late start today it's uh it's already
it's going on 6 30 right now
i'm gonna compliment the [ __ ] out of you
guys thanks bro do you guys want to just
like compliment me before we go yeah
i don't have anything pretty handy
little [ __ ] do this
but biting the hand of feet let me see
your hands dude
put them up let's put them up lower
you're out of frame come on you're out
of frame not the biggest
i've ever seen ab what's your ring size
that's what she said what what's your
ring size
she said not the biggest i've ever seen
precisely that's what she tells me
i don't know my ring size to be honest
okay wait do you not wear
a wedding ring i don't me neither i
don't either i have a tattoo on my
wedding phone though
is it representative of your marriage or
is it sure
sure i hope this doesn't make you sound
like a douche thank you zach
i'm just kidding you know yeah you could
say it you stopped go ahead you could
say it
well i wasn't gonna say anything i said
you said abi and you stopped
uh yeah it's yeah listen you don't love
me
chill dude no i i don't know it's okay
it's okay i'm thumbing
what more do you want yeah you're the
only [ __ ] that got a hug
yeah you got a hug what more do you want
i do love av i do i love all you guys
there's love for everybody here it's
okay alfredo loves me
oh you can get on though they got mad
when i got all the love last time
holding alfredo
getting the zach are you upset are you
upset that amy got a hug and you didn't
i mean he brought it up like four times
i i do cherish what you think about me
so i'm a little
you know i love you zach i am golden boy
i know i know
it's just like holding it's baby you
want to come give me a hug on camera
i would love to give you i'm over here
get on over there
get on over there do it quick though ian
you want a hug too
here we go all right zach live it up
live it up give her this moment zach
oh you're out of frame get wrecked
get [ __ ] you're out of frame zach
beautiful oh it's so cute
look the dogs don't like it nobody likes
this what are we still doing here
okay oh it's so cute guys come here
i'm not a hugger come on i'm not a
hugger i don't want to hug
i'm about to sexually harass you and
give me a hug
[Laughter]
you come you come give me a hug i'm
blasting with salt
oh yeah those things are awesome we got
a bug assault it's really cool it shoots
salt at flies it's [ __ ] awesome i've
shot it's not that cool
i've shot about two flies so far and
i've shot zach about
ten times wait you don't like it av
because he keeps shooting us with it
well that's not a defect with the
product that's just a problem with dan
hey gun hey guns don't shoot people
people do that's right
you need love dan all right guys so this
was our off the rails hope you guys have
fun
remember i actually you know what i
really want to do
remind me i want to do a trailer one
star rating and
frame it sam you got that
thank you sam's on it because i feel
it's important to commemorate
when i cast my meaningful vote
and i says listen i i take my product
reviews very seriously
you know i'm a social media star one
might say and so
take to yeah so reading social media
sites is really important
so i'm going to give it a one star
rating because i think they can improve
and i think they could find a better ceo
who's not a
yeah you might want to leave some
constructive feedback on uh
in addition to the one star or perhaps
some commentary on what you think about
the owner of the company right
that's ryan cavanaugh by the way so i'm
gonna i'm gonna do that and i'm gonna
frame it and i think that will look good
on all of our backdrops yeah maybe he'll
become the new ceo of trailer you never
know
you want me to be the ceo of trailer
well i mean [ __ ] kavanaugh you know
well we could find someone better than
me yeah or trailer could just stop
existing too i don't think anybody would
really miss it no
i'm gonna start an investing club where
everyone's just short i'm gonna start a
hedge fund where the only bet is
shorting trill
it's only one position it's a short
trailer
all right that's it um fun times eh
we'll be back on friday you know what it
is after dark
see you then peace